this morning Ford Motor Company will
unveil its plan to use wearable
technology to lighten the load on some
of its human workers exoskeleton vests
are being introduced in 15 Auto plants
in seven countries they are meant to
protect workers against repetitive
stress injuries the business of
providing technology to augment the
human workforce is expected to boom in
the coming years
first on CBS this morning Kris Van
Cleave takes us inside Ford's high-tech
plan
good morning it's not exactly the Iron
Man suit but this is the vest that Court
is giving to employees worldwide they
cost about six grand and the goal here
is to see if they'll reduce injuries
which is good for the workers and could
say Ford a lot of money for six years
now Nicholas Scott spends much of the
day on the Ford Mustang assembly line
reaching up hands in the air and turning
screws up 500 times a day but unlike
most of the workers at Ford's Flat Rock
plant God's gets a little extra boost
they call me rocket man or Superman all
the time and are mr. incredible it's an
exoskeleton that helps maintain good
posture adding up to 15 pounds of
support to each arm when it's raised up
exoskeletons date back to at least the
1960s when General Electric developed
this giant prototype for the military
and they've shown promise in helping
people with spinal cord injuries walk
analysts expect the exoskeleton market
to grow from 68 million in 2014 to 1.8
billion in 2025 it's about applying
technology the right way to reduce
injury Marty Smits an ergonomics expert
at Ford is focusing on shoulder injuries
they can cost $100,000 per employee to
fix and Rehab if you think about 15
pounds applied several thousand times
over the course of a shift we figure
it's about that the equip
not having to lift the massive 20
Mustangs per day for our me here at
Boeing's Charleston South Carolina plant
they've been evaluating suits like this
one for the last couple of years and
have found some real benefit to the
workers in fact the company believes the
day could come that this suit is
essentially just part of what workers
wear when they're building airplanes
structure mechanic tyrone washington
showed us how it works at the plants
training center all day you're talking
anywhere from five hundred to a thousand
fasteners joining the cria that's a lot
of lifting it's a lot of it even at
eight pound an IT problems that's you
know eight thousand pounds washington
was part of a six-month pilot program on
the line that builds the 787 are you
looking forward to the day that this is
part of the daily uniform i am it's a
dream come true to be able to be a part
of all new technology not every worker
who builds a ford like this mustang will
end up needing one of these suits
because not every job requires them but
they are going to become a lot more
common here on the line for CBS this
morning Kris Van Cleave Flat Rock
Michigan I mean the key that the point
that Kris makes about bringing down
medical costs for people who are working
on these assembly lines and how this can
be beneficial is makes economic sense
down I think Klaus on stay
he says he already has one the original
XO can do it without the exit cell